só hoje vou ensinar como fazer um placar
bem como é que haja muito baixo de
futebol o atlético ficou curioso e vanja
r 321 faro vai precisar de matar com uma
linha no bairro de picolé depois pra não
sair do papel quadriculado para os
ajudar a orientar e que vai acompanhar o
convite e pela linha mais pegada no maio
até a linha que devido para quem não vai
orientar e depois acabam de quadrinhos
pronto love fazer uma linha e do outro
também
agora vamos cortar vamos precisar saber
pelas partes lá atrás não vai ser
preciso martin e pronto agora outros
políticos prende com uma parte se manda
parte contornada e outra passou pela
linha central enquanto o time para
ajudar de trégua e cortar essa partida
pode usar um x-ato pronto é mais fácil
fazer outra parte igual por passar uma
linha através agora vejo
o ambiente depois pensar assim fui
taxado por orientar e vai pode usar esta
bola é mais rápida nas ruas podem usar a
sacola qualquer e pronta pois a escola é
só sobre o planeta
6.2 mas também pela língua e por um
tempo lá naquela direção do fmi que são
pele pois vamos formar executar cotizado
chefe sempre a apontar na direção
contrária de 34 anos agora usar aquelas
duas partes
fizemos no início ela é boa você quer
apenas aquelas pessoas daí as vezes
atrapalha
agora é só colar na região para orientar
em cima da linha de banho e o padrinho é
inicial
agora minha mãe e cortaram de usar os
dois documentários é a casa agora o
popular nessa para a prestação fique
centralizado na linha do maio e agora
por outra para outro lado mas de maneira
clicar em paralelo pois conseguiu juntar
compacta frente com um talento ímpar da
nossa caixa e uma colina sul
vou fazer agora marta jogos por hora
muita coisa aqui e agora brilha o
pauzinho lá dentro
eu ia tirar encurtar o chefe
vejam que aquela parte não vai exportar
também porque ele vai ficar o sistema
que faz rodar jogos agora faltam 102
tempinho atrás eu usei a falta das 6 da
tarde nós queremos a frente agora
reforçar vai deixar uma pequena folga
para não ficarmos deputada valas para
fazer uma trilha carioca volta a
inocente em portfólio em dois anos agora
falando aí por esse brasil vai ajudar a
ajudar jovens pra você poderá fazer para
sair agora te fazer bem colado à linha e
cortar vou ficar só com o parto maior
agora pode entrar menino maio cola e por
fim desta maneira vejam vendendo a fonte
disse que queria ficar à frente de
planta através de uma cabine por jovens
quanto eles comparam os bairros alto
pois vocês quiserem por um boneco em
cima de qualquer coisa e me ajuda muito
utilizada seja é tão leve que conquistar
o chefe aq tampinhas mais pequenos
pacientes fizeram de algo bom vai ser
quando voltar vai continuar a forçar em
um teste de rodas podem sair e pronto
vai expor em uma fita do lixa ou
qualquer coisa que aumentou o atrito
entre rodas e essa crise não vai
acontecer a equipe fez o nikkei rodada
deficiente
levo como fazer a minha própria boneca
alguma coisa a fazer a opção de se
agarrar a melhor contra a superfície e
pronto
agora vamos juntar as duas partes os
anos em baixo assim e eu era outro por
outro lado assim você fazer muita força
deixa assim o cargo souto
e era encaixar com a pele fazendo os
dois em paralelo agora passar um lápis
daquela partida para a outra em três
coletes e se já vocês conseguem dar uma
direção diferente
veja aqui o lado e do outro o tupi por
exemplo da penha presta para segurar o
elastic compute cloud print sócio
comercial do projeto e tem conseguido
fazer e antes de ir embora que só
anunciará uma parceria com a abc do
saber um pênalti aborda mais a parte
física e química e prontos gosta física
e química pode ir para onde quiser ver o
projeto meu plano está aqui embaixo a
coisa aqui e pronto é só isso só eu é o
próximo vídeo